[Music]
we're gonna talk about how Mac from It's
Always Sunny got ripped we're gonna talk
about what Kim Kardashian thinks of her
big butt but first look at this weird
video of Alex Trebek's beard
let's go Jillian it's not the beard it's
that it's like he can't grow it in
Friday yeah so there's a Twitter poll
right now if you should shave it or not
are you saying he should shave it it's
not a good beard I mean it doesn't look
great but that's his choice I feel like
women go through look changes all the
time and he grows out of beard and
everyone's freaking out okay respect
what it does say I did read that if you
have a beard you're hiding something him
without the bed he looks very cranky and
like he wants his tapioca with the beard
he's like I want tapioca where the
ladies at like he seems a lot cooler
he's something Trebek easy so ready for
the nursing I think the beard looks cool
and you know it's exciting I heard for
the finale of this season they're gonna
do a Twitter poll for whether or not
it's gonna shave his pubes it's gonna be
broadcast live on Twitch trying to go
for that 15 million per day what is a
very bad idea
yep pretty famously as a show you have
to answer the question the next story
now throw up that headline so Kim
Kardashian on a recent episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians said
that she actually doesn't like her big
butt what she's famous for and she said
that she quote cries about it on the
daily do we believe this at all she
hates her butt as much as she could just
return it or leave like is it leave it
on our soups not real bro it's fake at
least a car she has the couch cushion of
butts
DVDs Carl's in the CW's
Tapioca can we balance something on your
butt the little succulent yeah now you
see how hard it is to balance definitely
a buzz it's hard it is but and I was in
high school I was very self-conscious
about it and then when the Kardashians
made it work I was like damn I got an
ass so now I'm like not that Maris about
it because I don't want to say the
Kardashians helped my life yeah help my
self-esteem but they really did bring
back butts and as someone who
you know I can't I don't have boobs I
got to have something all right
so Hanna you're saying the Kardashians I
like that empowering you say mr. Trebek
if you like the beard all respect to you
so I'm gonna hear what you think of this
next story Hanna so this is mac from is
Always Sunny
he got unbelievably jacked at leading up
to the 13th season show that next photo
Jillian this is a real still where he
has like six pack abs and all this are
you on board with this - Hannah what do
you think like women would the TV show
and he's he still has a face I know
plenty of girls I this I know this is
real but it does look like it's the same
body except he's wearing a pregnancy
belly right yeah yeah they do they still
do have sex women are great people I
said it many times I said well I think I
don't know how your deal with women -
yellow seats ollio
factor child even look at guys it creeps
me out say some women murder yeah women
murder and I think that's exciting likes
to watch TV shows about does one yes I
do I love murder lady TV shows oh my god
everyone start watching killing Eve it's
really the best show of all time
Natasha main but killing you five stars
that's creepy Jordan you're getting
jacked right now right I'm trying
well how's that go it sucks cuz like I
was trying to do this bit of like oh I'd
be funny to get really really jacked and
so for the past few months I've been
going to the gym like really hard and I
did put on like I would say 10 pounds I
put on 10 pounds of
of muscle steel well it's not as
funny-looking as that like a good
contrast he did it better right
you really did his boast about it was so
great if we could read it in its
entirety Ryan you want to do the honors
oh it's over you got it here look it's
not that hard all you need to do is lift
wait six days a week stop drinking
alcohol don't eat anything after 7 p.m.
don't eat any carbs or sugar at all in
fact just don't eat anything you like
get the personal trainer from Magic Mike
sleep 9 hours a night run 3 miles a day
and have a studio pay for the whole
thing over a six to seven months span I
don't know why everyone's not doing this
it's a super realistic lifestyle and an
appropriate body image to compare
yourself it's doable but it's not like a
thing that you could do with a great
many people and money mm-hmm I have a
friend who's an ultra endurance athlete
like he's sponsored and he brought up
that the average person watches like 28
hours of TV a week and he's like if you
just took half of those hours and worked
out
you'd be an elite athlete and then I
thought about that so 14 hours a week
two hours a day it's like oh man still
not worth well you heard it here it's
not worth it just get the butt implants
don't work out yeah Jordan you got a
shout out that's yes s missus okay
Comedy Central we asked in the comments
what's your worst romantic gesture fail
and Paul Charmin
wrote I married my soul mate and then
three years later she divorced me
hey and welcome to lier expert we've
switched chairs and this is a game we're
about to play does that work
what did we give a topic that Natasha
must define a term for these teams will
then decide if she knows what she's
talking about and she's an expert or if
she's a liar
who was bullshitting then today's topic
will be foreign TV shows which I love
which she loves and then Natasha must
define the show that I named some of
these are real shows that you've seen
some of them are shows that she has not
seen and some of them are completely
made alright ready let's do it so our
first term is broadchurch right in Anna
Europe so broadchurch is a British TV
show starring a detective named Alec
hardy and he is investigating the murder
of a boy called Danny Latimer I think
it's true what do you think I know this
she made us a name guys if she made up
the names
they'd be insane Natasha names order
liar that's right this way next term is
three percent so three percent is what
is a mockumentary about the fall of the
financial crisis it's a Danish show so
it starts a guy named Kasper and a guy
named Lars
[Music]
so you know the name of our team is a
Minority Report right Larry we're more
right why why our industry
thriller web television show created by
head rock we era next one over here
middles & Co explain what that is it's
so this is actually a cooking
show actually it's hard scripted art
unscripted what's the host name the host
name is Valerie Valerie cherish - do we
have our answer
what is it liar not a real show not a
real show next turn Natacha get ready
dark Merengues dark place so this is a
Colombian show that is about an author
who lives in a small town and he writes
murder mysteries alright for the record
the name of my team is a minor reform
you gotta see the whole thing okay she's
why that is a real show it's a British
comedy show that isn't a lot there
actually who's a whore okay so we won
we're coming back this way next term is
keeping up appearances this is a show
about an old British lady named hyacinth
buckets
is she's a poor lady but she's trying to
seem fancy so instead of bucket she
tells everyone her name is hyacinth
Bouvier we have to answer why are expert
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so Jim our director told Jordan and I
about HGH human growth hormone so I
think we're just gonna start ordering it
and getting jacked yes yeah I don't know
maybe Internet longer as well will get
longer yeah oh just like grow that's
fine that's a new talent great well just
like everything will feel just like our
lives are getting isn't doesn't that
just keep you young apparently Tom pop
some and that's why he looks I'm so
making that easy
real quick thank you bro Aditi movement
I imagine it's like plant food like
whatever you put in your bouquet alright
time if you have any extra HGH please
send it our way please like comment
subscribe see you next time on every
damn day
[Music]